esta jornada concluyó con un barbecue en
la playa ofrecido para los líderes del
g-7 sus esposas y sus esposos pero este
segundo día de cumbre estuvo marcado por
la creciente tensión nuevamente por el
éxito entre el reino unido y la unión
europea y es que el primer ministro
británico boris johnson amenazó que si
el protocolo de irlanda del norte no es
modificado por la comunidad europea
entonces podría suspenderlo
unilateralmente horas antes los líderes
de esta comunidad como el presidente
francés la canciller alemana y la misma
jefe de la unión europea le advirtieron
a boris johnson que el 'break' si ya es
una ley que debe respetarse y no puede
modificarse sino que debe implementarse
y es que desde que el presidente en
vigencia irlanda del norte- que hace
parte de gran bretaña del reino unido
está en el mercado común de la unión
europea lo que hace que enviar productos
desde cualquier ciudad británica se
considere un tipo de exportación lo que
es
generando por supuesto problemas de
abastecimiento de otro lado se espera
que este domingo cuando concluya esta
cumbre del g7 la primera cara a cara en
dos años la primera de joe by de como
presidente de eeuu y la última de angela
merkel como canciller de alemania
después de más de 15 años en el cargo se
espera que los países del g7 anuncien en
la firma de la declaración de carl bis
bay comprometiéndose con recursos y
acciones para evitar que pandemias como
la del cob y 19 se repitan y además con
la donación de millones de vacunas para
los países en desarrollo